vor allem hinter den menschen in münchen
liegen ein abend und eine nacht des
schreckens
wir alle stehen noch unter dem eindruck
der bilder und der berichte der
augenzeugen
neun menschen die am freitagabend noch
einkäufe erledigen oder rasch etwas
essen wollten sind tot
nach jetzigem stand getroffen von den
kugeln eines einzelnen täters in der
runde der zuständigen bundesminister
haben uns gerade der bundesinnenminister
und die spitzen der sicherheitsbehörden
über den derzeitigen stand der
ermittlungen informiert
bundesinnenminister thomas de maizière
wird in kürze auch presse und
öffentlichkeit ausführlich über das ins
bild setzen was zu diesem zeitpunkt
feststeht
thomas de maizière ist fortlaufend im
engsten kontakt mit dem bayerischen
innenminister joachim herrmann wie auch
ich mit dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten horst seehofer
die zusammenarbeit der bayerischen
behörden und des bundes war von beginn
an eng und nahtlos im namen der
bundesregierung danke ich dafür wie alle
und das sage ich auch im namen der
ganzen bundesregierung wir alle trauern
mit schwerem herzen um die die nie mehr
zu ihren familien zurückkehren werden
den familien den eltern und kindern für
die heute alles leer und sinnlos
erscheint sage ich persönlich wie auch
im namen vieler vieler menschen in
deutschland wir teilen ihren schmerz wir
denken an sie
wir leiden mit ihnen unsere gedanken
gehen auch zu den zahlreichen verletzten
mögen sie rasch aber vor allem wieder
vollkommen gesund werden und alle
unterstützung finden die sie dafür
brauchen so ein abend so eine nacht sind
schwer zu ertragen für jeden von uns
sie sind umso schwerer zu ertragen als
wir so viele schreckensnachrichten bin
ganz weniger tage hinnehmen müssten
da war der anschlag von nizza
die menschenverachtung mit der täter
dort ein lastwagen in die menschen
steuerte und 84 menschen tötete dann der
unfassbar grausam axt angriff in einem
zug bei würzburg
die schwerverletzten ringen weiter mit
den folgen
meine gedanken sind auch heute bei ihnen
die genauen hintergründe und motive die
diesen mann der vor gut einem jahr als
flüchtling nach deutschland gekommen war
islamistisch radikalisiert und bei
seiner tat geleitet haben werden weiter
intensiv aufgeklärt
gestern dann die morde in münchen
immer sind es orte an denen jeder von
uns hätte sein können
so kann ich jeden verstehen der heute
mit beklommenheit auf eine menschenmenge
zugeht der im hinterkopf die frage hat
ob er dann sicher ist was kann uns in
solchen momenten zuversicht geben
ich denke dabei zuerst an unsere
großartigen sicherheitskräfte die
münchner polizei die ganze bayerische
polizei mit unterstützung der
bundespolizei
sie haben gestern und in der nacht hoch
professionell gearbeitet
sie haben eine million statt in einer
überstunden unübersichtlichen lage
gesichert sie haben besonnen
kommuniziert sie waren und sind im
besten sinne helfer und beschützer der
bürgerinnen und bürger
sie geben alles genauso wie die
rettungskräfte einen besonderen dank
richtig auch an die münchnerinnen und
münchner
sie sind den anweisungen der polizei
ruhig nachgekommen
sie haben einander beigestanden
wohnungen für fremde geöffnet die nicht
mehr nach hause kam und haben damit
gezeigt wie wir in einer freien und mit
menschlichen gesellschaft zusammenleben
in dieser freiheit und mitmenschlichkeit
liegt unsere größte stärke
seit gestern abend erreichen uns auch
viele botschaften aus dem ausland
regierungen und persönlichkeiten aus
vielen ländern lassen uns deutsche
wissen dass sie uns uns denken dass sie
an unserer seite stehen und wenn nötig
hilfe anbieten dafür bedanken wir uns
sehr
es ist gut zu wissen dass es auch unter
völkern
diese solidarität gibt und dass wir
viele freunde haben im kampf gegen
gewalt und terrorismus
meine damen und herren wir werden
herausfinden was genau hinter der tat in
münchen stand wir werden auch nicht
ruhen bis wir präzise wissen wie sich
der täter von würzburg radikalisierte
der staat und seine sicherheitsbehörden
werden auch weiterhin alles daran setzen
um die sicherheit und die freiheit aller
menschen in deutschland zu schützen
vielen dank